all right we're now live
so this is reading number two
public reading of some parts
of my now 10 year old book
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
turns out the
first reading was quite well received so
we're going to do a sec well we'll do a
whole bunch of readings
until we get all the way through the
book and
last time we went over the introduction
and two sections principles of selection
of documents
and debate or debates today i'm going to
read about
11 pages from the historical
introduction
so there's three sections to that
general background to the christian
philosophy debates the debates french
context
and historical development and phases of
the christian philosophy debates this is
all part of the
big uh introduction to the the
translations so with no
further ado i'm going to
start reading this is on page 10 and
this is the section
general background to the christian
philosophy
debates the debates took place within a
long
prepared and developed complex
historical context
one of modern western culture in general
and more particularly the context of
modern french intellectual
cultural and religious life given
france's major importance in the history
of the modern west a dialectical
relationship held between the more
general and more particular contexts
both of them
affecting and modifying each other by
turns
still the term the notion and the
problem of christian philosophy
arise in the broader context long before
the francophone debates
and accordingly it makes sense to study
that context before focusing
specifically
on the more detailed and convoluted
french scene a few words of disclaimer
are required before sketching the main
features of these contexts
what i supply here are meant only to be
broad outlines useful for locating
the figures text concepts and
terminology of the debates within their
historical contexts
an adequate history of the concept of
christian philosophy
of the debates let alone of all the
other historical matters comprising
their context
far exceeds what can be provided in this
book
a full history of the 1930s french
christian philosophy debates indeed
deserves to be written
but that project must be deferred to
another volume
so here's the subsection the term
christian
philosophy it is entirely correct to
claim
that the term christian philosophy was
not given a precise signification
prior to the 1930s debates if what is
meant by this
is either that many of the authors who
employed the term did not specify
precisely what they meant by it or
that those using the term had no general
agreement on its reference meanings
determinant limits exemplars or
embodiments
even after the debates both of these
conditions arguably
still held clearly no universal
consensus
emerged despite the efforts of some
authors to state what in their views
at least all the catholic participants
in the debates had agreed upon
one aspect of this lack of agreement was
that the proponents of conflicting
positions typically interpreted their
interlocutors either as failing to
provide
specific meaning to the term or as
providing a wrong
meaning concealing some implicit
vagueness or
incoherence study of the terms history
is illuminating in this respect for it
reveals that different authors have
provided the term with a variety of
distinguishable meanings
and that general agreement provides no
satisfactory index for deciding whether
the term has been assigned precise
significations
several different historical uses of the
term that provided fodder for the
debates can be distinguished but first
noting a key point about the term
philosophy is imperative
namely that examination of its own
history
and of the forms of thought given the
name philosophy
indicates that philosophy has itself
borne
many fundamentally different meanings
through the years
and from one school or movement to
another
accordingly the meaning of christian
philosophy would
vary considerably if literary monuments
can be taken
as indicative the term christian
philosophies was explicitly but only
occasionally
used from the early christian era
through the middle ages
and into early modernity expressions
similar in content
and formulation were used in christian
antiquity as a few examples
show justin martyr called himself a
christian philosopher and wrote of the
philosophy according to christ tatian
who would later
lapse into gnosticism contrast our
philosophy with your philosophy that is
the philosophy
of the greeks clement of alexandria
regarded pagan philosophy as a
preparation for the gospel assimilable
by
christian intellects and strove for and
extolled a
christian gnosis loctancias
unwilling to concede philosophy the
title of wisdom so long as it lacked
true religion
nevertheless suggests the possibility of
as he says collecting the truth which
had been dispersed among individuals
and scattered among sects augustine
himself
though apparently only once as such used
the term christian philosophy but
came for his followers to exemplify one
of its models later in the east maximals
the confessor
would assign to the christian philosophy
three objects the commandments
the doctrine and the faith and gregory
of sinai would term
the true philosopher one who has
attained consciously and directly a
supernatural union with god
in the west as in the east ascetic and
contemplative christian monasticism
was termed heavenly philosophy
so that life learning prayer and
meditation structured by
saint benedict's rule could be called
the philosophy
of saint benedict later
in early modernity the term itself or
those quite similar would crop up
in the writings of thinkers as varied in
outlook as erasmus john
calvin saint francis de sal nicholas
malbros
and even renee descartes needless to say
the term took on quite different
meanings and was used with varied
degrees
of philosophical reflection or conscious
intent
several fairly prevalent types of
intentional use whereby works are
entitled
christian philosophy are worth
distinguishing some authors
come to it to come to use it in order to
designate new philosophical essays
often but not exclusively of augustinian
leanings and views attempting to develop
philosophy in harmony
or in light of christian faith in other
cases manuals
containing systematic arrangements of
scholastic philosophy
were labeled christian philosophy a use
continuing into the 20th century
in application to textbooks and here
i have just a few examples i'm going to
read the footnote
22. a late 19th century example is the
1894 textbook christian philosophy
descriptively subtitled based on the
principles of the best
scholastic authors adapted from the
french of brother louis of
boise by the brothers of the christian
schools a more contemporary example is j
glover johnson's 1944 high roads of the
universe an introduction to christian
philosophy
intended for the high school level
alexander spetz's
recent revealingly named samarium
philosophy christianity and unum curses
philosophic
unis
appeared just before the christian
philosophy debates
all right coming back to the text itself
um
here we go uh christian philosophy also
became a term
readily used by historians of philosophy
designating in particular either the
philosophies of late antiquity
in the middle ages or more more broadly
philosophies developed by christian
authors
including those in modernity
pope leo the 13th encyclical attorney
potress
heightened the prominence and also
reflected increase in use of the term
although the document does not use the
term in its body
an unofficial subtitle containing
christian philosophy was
quickly appended james weiszepple uh
observes french catholics have been
calling for a philosophy catien since
the 1840s
sans severino civil to catalika and
other italian thomas had made the term
philosophia christiana
popular since the 1850s and even france
heirloom
commenting commenting at length on a
teeny patrice in
schtimen aus maria lach immediately
after its promulgation
related it to the restoration de
christian philosophy
leo the 13th encyclical thus increased
the terms currency
but christian philosophy already had the
long
and tangled history of different senses
noted earlier
it could take on and play off a host of
interrelated
and office often ambiguously specified
meanings
so that by the years of the debates
there was a growing recognition
even among its proponents that its
meaning or meanings needed to be
discerned distinguished and clarified
at the same time matters had also come
to a head precisely because the very
possibility and the nature of its
referent had long been called into
question
and in many quarters both rationalist
and catholic
already dismissed here's the next
section
modernity modern philosophy and
christianity
momentous intellectual changes and
developments took place
in modernity and these would eventually
produce a climate in which
christian philosophy could for many be
regarded as an oxymoron
or at most one of philosophy's
backwaters or ghettos a topic or
tradition of mere antiquarian interests
destined eventually to disappear
advanced already extant literature
presents the details of these
developments interpretation and
arrangement of which
are matters of continued research
dispute and scholarly controversy
so here only the broadest and hopefully
least controversial
developments and only those particularly
contributing to the general intellectual
context
of the debates need be discussed
these primarily concern changes in
viewpoints regarding philosophy
its essential nature its conditions and
requirements for successful practice and
development and its legitimate objects
and projects these also very importantly
include philosophy's relations with
christianity including recurring
problems
conceptualized as those are the
relations between
reason and faith the natural and the
supernatural
but also involving re-examination of
control or subordination of
philosophical inquiry
pedagogy and discussion to religious
ends disciplines and
institutions as an ongoing discipline
capable of being communicated and
inculcated through teaching
of being embodied in certain figures
texts movements schools and approaches
philosophy and modernity came to be
reconceptualized in
radically new ways not only by those who
identify themselves in genuine
philosophy with the sets of projects
text thinkers and methods
that come to be called and regarded as
modern but
also by those who for one reason or
another opposed and condemned these
this is not to say that throughout
modernity
even down to the present there have not
always been many thinkers whose
philosophical practice
and conception of philosophy was more
traditional
deliberately continuing the thought of
antiquity or the middle ages nourished
by
and aiming at harmony with christian
faith life and thought
but those were not the voices that
characteristically took part or were
given parts
in modernities and modern philosophies
ongoing
self-defining of course there was no one
single universally agreed upon
definition of philosophy in modernity
wrangling about precisely what
constitutes genuine philosophy
proper philosophical practice method and
aims
is an important part of modern
philosophy's content and heritage
as are the dual motifs of making an
entirely new and
last scientific and rational beginning
of an engaging in critique of the past
and present forms of philosophical
thought still
it is possible to disentangle several
generalizable features of philosophy in
modernity relevant here
first philosophers came to regard and to
represent philosophy as essentially
autonomous treating this alternately is
an assumed starting point
an instrumental trope employed in
polemics an ideal project
always yet to be achieved or even a
positive effect
provided by philosophy to humanity
whereby philosophy was not only either
to be or already emancipated but also
emancipating
both for those engaged in it and for
society culture and intellectual life
in general this emancipation was viewed
as the human minds and reasons
liberation from the weight
and restrictions imposed and perpetuated
by a number of putative evils
religious authorities and dogmas
superstitions and prejudices unhealthy
passions of all sorts
religious enthusiasm particularities of
perspective restricted by one's
background community or traditions
and private interests whether naked or
disguised of individuals classes and
institutions
this emancipation would take place
through rejection
of the past and the traces of the past
in the present
and by discovery generation application
and consolidation of new methods
for attaining truth certainty and
knowledge in the rapidly expanding
sciences
in philosophy and in all of its allied
disciplines and these new methods
would involve at the same time expansion
and restriction
of philosophies proper objects its
legitimate projects
and the very capacities and scope of
reason
both in its practical exercise and in
metaphilosophical reflection
a philosophical analog to the spirit of
puritanism
is discernible in this ever criticizing
the contemporary philosophical
establishment for retaining too much
superstitious credence
in yet uncritiqued assumptions shared
with past thought and present through
unenlightened thinkers and institutions
equally visible in examples such as
descartes methodological doubt
hobbes condemnation of practical all
past and present thought is unscientific
and socially deleterious
hume's rhetorical consignment of books
containing of statements
uh consisting of statements
unreconstructable statements of fact or
abstract connections of ideas to the
flames
cons insistence on the necessity of
following his copernican revolution
into deeply impoverished philosophy and
faith all the way down
to the different varieties of positivism
scientism
and pragmatism generated during the 19th
and 20th centuries
second in this process of emancipation
philosophy entered anew into a range of
relations with christianity whether
understood in terms of its central texts
doctrines beliefs key thinkers schools
of thought institutions ways of life
spiritual communities sacraments or even
its ultimate
object and origin the triune god these
relations
range from outright hostility to the
compromises of concordance and separated
philosophy
to attempts at tailoring christianity to
one or another a presumed shape of
rationality
all of these types of relations point
towards a basic
prioritization of philosophy over
christianity
of putatively unaided and natural reason
over revelation
faith and religious life four certain
philosophical perspectives developed and
articulated within the perspectives of
modernity for example thomas paine's
crude and militant dayism in the age of
reason
there could be no question of
christianity in whatever form being
allowed to remain in contact with
let alone make demands upon or
contribute to philosophy
philosophy should be outright hostile to
christianity particularly to
institutions
that claim to embody and transmit it
such as the catholic church
holding these to represent a type and
source of despotism
promoting heteronomy dependency and
immaturity of the human mind
for others for example descartes despite
professions of respect for theology
the christian religion and the church
and despite developing a philosophy in
consonance with it at points philosophy
could be done
just as well in the absence of faith as
in its presence it could be done by the
natural light
relying on a reason fundamentally the
same in nature scope and capabilities in
the believer as in the unbeliever
or by appeal to experience regarded as
fundamentally similar
from from one human subject to the next
provided the philosopher is attentive
enough
and not led astray by passion irrational
belief or interest
another possibility was that of
admitting elements of the christian
religion into philosophy
but only after subjecting them to reason
scrutiny and censorship
taking them out of the hands of any
religious institution or tradition
depending on whose reason carries out
the critique there will be more or less
christian material rationalized and
assimilated
in the case of spinoza's teological
political treaties or kant's reason
within the limit
religion within the limits of reason
alone for example decidedly less is
taken in from christianity than in
locke's essay
or in hegel's works it's also possible
as is the case for many modern philosoph
philosophers to philosophize as a
christian explicitly trying to produce a
philosophy
satisfying both reasons and
christianity's demands while remaining
confined fundamentally within
assumptions and horizons germane to
modern philosophy
and yet another possibility on its face
involving less
over commitments is that one can simply
ignore christianity
citing reasons ranging from its
uh inapplicability or irrelevance to
one's own interest whether personal or
professional and philosophical to the
view that religion
is something to be entirely outgrown and
left behind in the continuous
contemporary development
of humanity modernity
also inherited the scandal of a
fragmented christendom
in which a variety of churches condemned
with and made counter claims or against
each other
some protestant churches congregations
movements or factions within
churches themselves hastened the
processes of secularization identifying
themselves some enthusiastically and
some
uneasily uneasily with the ideals or the
course of enlightenment being swept
along its intellectual currents
others turned in other directions
towards legalism towards
fidaisms of varied shapes and emphases
or to devotional and emotionally
centered religion
many of these currents could also be
found in one corner or another
one movement or thinker of the roman
catholic church
although over time many of their
determinate forms would be brought into
consideration and come under
condemnation
the different churches claims about each
other's superstition authoritarianism
and unamendability to rational argument
and persuasion
furnished secular opponents with
ready-made
charges against particular religious
bodies and traditions
and thereby material eventually
generalizable into claims about
religion's fundamental irrationality
third modern philosophy developed within
and came more and more to articulate its
own
self-referential and self-confirming
historical perspective
a development not entirely surprising
since something similar
takes place in other ages cultures and
intellectual movements and communities
it's also unsurprising that this
historical perspective would
uncritically draw on
and perpetuate what were and remain
essentially unquestioned dogmas about
philosophy's own autonomy
its relations with christianity and the
nature and effects of religion
the key question that arises is
as with any historical narrative
assessing whether it's an adequate one
one that does
justice in this case to the intellectual
content value depth and coherence of
christian thought
or whether it involves systematic
distortion even deliberate ignorance of
past intellectual developments and
thereby the full intellectual riches
still available in christianity's
present from the
viewpoint of many modern thinkers the
patristic era in the middle ages even
for some the reformation amount to
philosophical wastelands ages of
fundamentally
irrational faith when speculation and
theory
were carried out under the yoke of dogma
and authority
punctuated occasionally by glimmers of
fragmentary genuinely
philosophical thought generally in
revolt against or subversive
of religion this produces
a self-reinforcing dynamic knowing
already that there's nothing of value to
recover from these eras
one will not waste the time and effort
of reading and reflecting on sources
from that
era particularly when adequately
understanding and appreciating texts
a patristic and medieval thought
requires entering
some degree into context traditions webs
of assumptions
and intertextual references in many
circles
to identify oneself with a thinker or
school of these periods
is to condemn oneself to the status of
an antiquarian or worse of one
who wishes to resuscitate and impose on
others the failed and rightly discarded
philosophies of the past philosophies
that were not really philosophies
in a rigorous sense assigned by one of
the modern school systems
or figures of philosophy modern day
schools or movements deliberately
continuing or recovering pre-modern
thoughts such as neo-scholasticism
thus become triply problematic
they were triply problematic for in
addition to presuming to think according
to the mind of the saint thomas
neo-scholastics are typically practicing
and believing christians
a condition bound to interfere with
philosophies autonomy and rationality
and worse yet they take directives from
an institution both religious
and in the view of many moderns
quintessentially anti-modern the roman
catholic church
if the attitude of many non-catholic
modern philosophers towards catholic
thought
could be summarized in a single sentence
it would be
it has been tried it has produced its
definite results which have been found
lacking and now its time has passed
and it must be conceded that the main
developments of roman catholic
philosophical thought were not
particularly distinguished or successful
from early modernity to the revival that
attorney potress consolidated
here i'm going to read footnote 25.
one might argue this point pointing to
towards a mall brush or to pascal both
singled out by some interlocutors during
the debates as genuine representatives
of christian philosophy and personally i
would claim that pascal
as the thinker is of the first order but
here what must be taken into
consideration is the historical effects
of their respective philosophies and
their ability
to provide philosophies that could be
used by further catholic thinkers to
fruitfully engage
modernity quite arguably pascal's most
important direct influence was on
blondel
all right back to the text scholasticism
did
undergo a decline in degeneration before
and during early modernity about which
jill
saul remarked albertus thomas scotus
alchemists all contributed to the ruin
of medieval philosophy
in the exact measure in which they
neglected the search for truth to
exhaust themselves
in barren controversies about the
formula
in which it was to be expressed while
the dominicans maintained a tradition of
continued study and thinking through st
thomas catholic philosophical thought
came to run in many other currents
most notably augustinian ones those of
cartesian
in some cases those of maulbrush uniting
it with the augustinian
and later those of conscient influence
and particularly after the french
revolution
the eventually condemned rivolets of
laminaes into maestrism's
traditionalism and rosamini's ontologism
in market and welcome contrast the half
century prior to the 1930s christian
philosophy debates
witnessed a renaissance of catholic
philosophical thought
most particularly through the revival of
tomism both making possible and
furthered by the
1879 attorney pontras raising tomism
again to a leading school of catholic
philosophical thought with important
institutional effects
ranging from the establishment of new
centers for domestic studies
for example in leuven to the undertaking
of a critical edition of thomas's works
to tomism's assuming an integral role in
catholic university and seminary
formation
albeit often through manual-based
neo-scholasticism to proliferation of
articles books and conferences on his
thought
these new emphases are the effect of
provoking further studies of other
medieval thinkers
eventually leading to fuller recovery of
the diversity of medieval philosophies
intellectual
riches there were additional factors in
this renaissance more specific to the
french intellectual milieu
to which we must now turn and that leads
us into the section the debates french
context
which i will reserve for another reading
uh the next reading of reason fulfilled
by revelation the 1930s christian
philosophy debates
in france so we're now up to page 21
making some progress a lot more to go
because the book
the text of of the book uh takes us all
the way
to page
282. so it's going to be a while we'll
be
chipping away at this all summer i think
all right so jed
asks question for the q a is this book a
good place to get an intro to the wider
thinking of the participants
or the contents of the debates too
specific thinking of blondel
in specific um neither i would say it's
uh the historical introduction gives you
some
some you know background on
the main thinkers also a lot about the
debates themselves the debates are
nested within the
larger projects of the people involved
obviously you wouldn't want to take the
four things that i've translated here
as the totality of blondel's philosophy
you would want to read oxio 1893
and you know some of his other earlier
stuff that's been translated
unfortunately the problem with blondel
is that most things
are not translated into english at this
point if you can read french then you're
you're golden but
you know that's not the case
pretty much everything you'll saw has
written i think is translated into
english in one way or another
um i think you can say the same thing
for jacques maritan
um some of the other
key figures in the debates like marcel's
stuff is pretty much all translated
antonin de certian
not so much uh breyer if you're
interested in him or brunch rig their
stuff i think is
brady's history of philosophy has been
translated
i'm not so sure about brunchfig leon
brunchfig
and actually like some of the people who
get involved later on
uh like you know lev shestop for example
his athens and jerusalem
were some very late contributions to the
debates
that's actually been translated as a
single volume it was a set of um
essays right so yeah
but another thing too is i've put a link
to a internet encyclopedia philosophy
article that i wrote
quite a long time ago back when i was
doing a lot of work on the christian
philosophy debates
and that's kind of a good overview of
the people and the positions in the
debates
all right um
mark says bit of a weird question but do
you think you could consider your work
here as under the broad umbrella of
modernity studies
yeah it depends on how broad the
umbrella is and what we mean by
modernity studies i i was thinking as i
was rereading this
that you know there's all this
discussion about post-modernism and most
people
talking about post-modernism are full of
crap and you know using the term
basically
uh as a slur word and they have no idea
what they were talking about including
some people who have published books on
post-modernism
where kant is a post-modernist or stuff
like that it's interesting because
because um
you know that that term postmodernism
emerges of course
late in the 20th century and
there's a book by jacques mara 10 when
he was still under the influence of
accion frances called auntie modern
i don't know if it's been translated or
not
and if it is it's not to marutin's
credit
you know um because he's um
there he's criticizing you know
descartes rousseau and luther
as like the people who destroyed
everything you know and
it's funny because if you think about
somebody like descartes right we would
now typically think of him as a typical
in
you know enlightenment intellectual not
postmodern at all he's actually a
foundationalist
and yet you know from the perspective i
mean what this means is
modern is a slippery term that gets used
in all sorts of ways
some people are too modern some people
aren't modern enough post-modern itself
comes out of the modern right there is
no post-modern without the modern
uh and it plays off of it a lot of
people are you know are
passed using that term woody asks about
jordan peterson jordan peterson when it
comes to the postmodern is
garbage you know he's relying on stephen
hicks
uh work which is you know if you know
much about the people that he's writing
about you're like wow that's
some weird ways of construing these
things it's it's it's you know
it's sort of like the the um
[Music]
what do we call it like it's sort of
like the the what the thomistic manuals
were which was
terrible philosophy they were like
textbook very schematic
you know descartes and and descartes are
errors and the errors of
continuism and stuff like that and then
thomas was the hero at the end
i kind of think that that's about that's
that's pretty much the best you're going
to get out of
a lot of the critics of postmodernism um
with the exception of like interesting
marxist critics like terry eagleton
or um harrison who wrote the politics at
god's funeral back in the 80s
jed says okay great i will check that
article out it's time to quit being a
coward and open oxy on 1893.
um yeah i mean accion 1883 is is
is difficult but i'll i'll tell you kind
of a funny story
so there's two translations in english
of it out there
there's uh james somerville did a
translation and then oliver blossot
who by the way if you want to know about
blondel oliver blanchette has an amazing
like thousand page
intellectual biography of blondel that
he published i want to say around like
2010
2011. i had been you know working on
blown dell for about
12 13 years by that point and done a lot
of historical research there were things
in there that i didn't even know
and so so that's that's actually called
marie of philosophical life
and if you read that and then read acts
you know 1893 i think it could be easier
to um get through blondel is not a great
writer
he's sort of like hegel not as bad as
hegel but
he is not a he's not a stylist
um so you know
his his prose is kind of muddy um it's
not actually
better in french than this in english so
anyway i'll leave a blanchette i was i
was corresponding with
him years and years and years ago when i
was a grad student
and i asked him why did you make a new
translation of
oxygen 1893 and he said well i was
teaching blondel in my classes
and i found somerville's translation
because it has so many
badly translated things to be so
frustrating i was like
i'm gonna have to do a translation
myself and a translation is a lot of
work right so
you don't you don't want to do a
translation if you don't have to but he
bit the bullet
into the translation and his translation
is good you know
so all right um
mark smith what do you think of the
argument that modernity began with akam
and that descartes was late nihilist i
think any uh thing that tries to say
that a big historical period
there will be exceptions to this but a
big historical period began with
this is always [ __ ] i mean it's
historical periods are like
constellations of things so ockham
you know is is part of it and um
so are the you know the rise of uh
certain the rise of the noblest the robe
in in
france and you know changes
in um navigation
and there's like all sorts of factors i
think i think that people
who want to say that that like you know
this period began with this person
almost
unless you really have something where
you can say
yeah this person was it um
like you know analytic philosophy did it
begin with fraga no
did it begin with russell did it begin
with more who's the one that began with
it doesn't work that way you know things
complex
philosophical or cultural movements
have complexes of
causes and so you know there is a really
prevalent thing out there that
usually places it on both occam and
scotus right
the radical orthodoxy types sometimes
fall into that but a lot of catholics do
as well
um and i think you know that's it's kind
of a mistake
um
all right some thanks here any other
questions about
like the milieu that we were talking
about in france
or in western thought more
generally or uses of the term christian
philosophy
that's the stuff that we've
discussed there we're going to move into
these these sections the debates french
context i'll read you
while people are thinking of questions
some of the headers so there's catholic
thought and rationalism
the catholic intellectual renaissance in
france which looks like it goes on for
quite a few pages
uh the main participants in the debates
conte
context conflicts and christian
philosophy
[Music]
um well that's a long section too
um
eric zone and phenomenology there's a
little digression on
on that uh historic and then we go into
historical development and phases of the
christian philosophy debates
and that's that's a shorter section
we'll do a reading on that later
but that one's only like seven pages so
we probably won't have as much reading a
lot more
q a all right thomas says a cool topic i
was big
into e uh
who's he ate song emil bravier
um who would also be an e
uh atn born of course but he's not
particularly
well known um
yeah who could e be um
oh okay
i accidentally typed enter okay well
who so who is it who are you big into
um i mean you know a lot of the people
that
that were involved in the debates were
like
pretty big name philosophers i think
that's that's part of how they got their
publishing contracts and they got
into the the journals that the debates
were taking
place in because if you were just some
schmucks from nobody maybe they they
wouldn't be as likely to publish you
i don't think that you know peer review
was uh the order of the day for a lot of
these journals like the you know review
de metaphysique
morale which uh who was running that it
was
um leo not noel
somebody else uh the one who proposed
the debate between
jill saw and breyer with brunchfig and
mauritan as
seconds for them all right uh
jed says with a very secular focus of
the french republic were these debates
taken seriously in secular circles
yes and no that's a good question
so one person who writes about them and
i believe
it's in signs is
maurice marilyn ponti and it's clear
that marilyn ponte has not
studied the debates adequately because
his
little presentation of it mangles the
picture entirely
and he's kind of dismissive of it um
you know a lot of the other people that
fit into what was being called
existentialism
at the time were not not that into it
unless they were religious
existentialists like marcel or etienne
born or
or people like that um
you know two two of the people who were
involved in the debates
very early on uh emil brelier
and leon brunchfig clearly they thought
that that the debates were quite
important because they
they got involved in it and brunchfig
ends up
writing a book later on
i'm blanking on the name but i think i
could probably easily find it in the
bibliography if i can't then then we got
a problem here
uh yeah okay so well he's still writing
things like uh
in 1935 uh religion philosophy and the
review to metaphysique
morale um
[Music]
where is he brunchfig
he brought out a book anyway it's sort
of reflecting on it
and i i do think that the the topic
oh here it is yeah yeah la rezo and
religion in 1939.
i do think that the topic in some
respects suffered
from the fact that you know
germany was rearming there was this
whole
you know worry about um fascism and
integral nationalism
and national socialism as and also you
know bolshevik communism
and what liberal democracies were going
to do in relation to it
and so the debate in effect got it got
eclipsed i would say
um all right so so gerard says jill saw
in college
uh yeah so i mean jill is an interesting
guy well worth reading
um he he was
fortunate when it comes to like
english-speaking areas that he
taught in toronto and so he had a huge
effect over here
and as i mentioned in the the previous
section and in the previous reading
a lot of americans and and um other
english speakers
only know the debates as the jill some
braggier
gilsan von steinbergen debates and they
don't realize how
vast the complex of these debates were
in part because you'll sew himself did a
little bit of propagandizing along those
lines
as did mara 10. so yeah
um
all right
rishab says analytic or continental
philosophy
uh i don't know what you're asking um
this this isn't something that fits into
either this is
you know stuff happening in france but
what we call continental philosophy over
here
is a very narrow window into
mostly french and german and a bit of
italian sometimes spanish or other
people's philosophy sometimes check
you know um but
what we call continental philosophy is
only a
few bits of what what french philosophy
actually is doing um and so
analytic philosophy as we know it today
was sort of
in its infancy and birth throws
in in places like america
uh in the 1930s it was taking off pretty
good in britain but
it was kind of kind of you know wide
spread over a number of different
uh ideas continental philosophy
isn't understood as continental
philosophy in europe it's
understood as like different things of
philosophy and phenomenologists might be
very different from
uh marxists might be very different from
structuralists
you know and a lot of these these people
involved in these debates were
doing other things that we don't even we
don't even generally teach
you know so all right
uh jed one last question is jill stone's
book on medieval philosophy
generally accurate in your view he's got
a lot of books on medieval philosophy
are you asking about the spirit of
medieval philosophy
um that's that's not a bad um
book um i mean i i can't think of
anything offhand i'd have to go and
reread it
where i'd be like nah he's he's off base
on that um
it's it's kind of thematically arranged
so he's like
here's a topic here's the thinkers who
had something to say about it here's how
what they were doing is different than
how we typically approach
things a lot of what he's doing in that
book is essentially hermeneutics
those by the way were his gifford
lectures um so presented to a popular
audience
thomas says i've called myself an
eclectic to what degree would you say
aligned with tomism or
who was of his interpreters do you enjoy
like aristotle or existential
so i like tomisms that actually read
thomas aquinas and
and constantly go back to the text and
try to remain
faithful to the spirit of saint thomas
rather than turning things into
formulaic you know
let's find a pigeonhole for everything
schematism
and um there's there's so many different
varieties of tomism out there
um i do draw on thomas aquinas in some
of my
stuff like you know for example when i'm
doing work on anger i think his
his realization i i don't believe that
we have an erasable appetite like he
thinks
uh which i think is a distortion of um
uh aristotelian thumbos and
a little bit too schematic but um i
think that his recognition that anger is
is about the difficult good
is brilliant you know um
so there's that and then you know who i
mean who's my favorite thomas
uh aleister mcintyre
who's you know an aristotelian thomas
and a marxist still in many respects and
a uh um
you know person who's studied a lot of
stuff and brought a lot of things along
um i like readings you'll see i like
reading marathon i get some stuff
out of them there were a lot of thomas
who were influenced by maurice blondell
antonin sertian i think is a hidden gem
that that a lot of people left behind
and
should probably spend their time reading
because he's quite quite brilliant
um you know but i i don't worry so much
about
like who's of this with this school or
something like that i look for what what
i can take from them
that i find interesting all right uh
here's a good question mark from mark
did similar debates occur in
other countries or did these emerge
specifically in relation to the french
milieu so the french milieu is the
crystal
around which other things crystallized
you could say and none of the other
things that happened were as big as the
francophone debates but it did spin off
into some discussions in spanish
journals and it
provoked a american catholic
philosophical association
meeting which was devoted specifically
to
christian uh philosophy as as a topic
i think that was around 1934
35
there were
there were um later reformed protestant
debates that that started taking place
in the 1940s after the war
um that were made you know reference
back to these debates
i mean i i should look at the historical
uh
the bibliography because that kind of
helps out so
um
yeah so like uh prizwara prishwara
in 1933 has this catalina metaphysique
metaphysique and stiminder zeit so he's
got his
his thing to the pulse
romanelli writes a piece in the revista
di philo sofia neo scholastica in
toronto all signification del conchetto
the philosophy of christiana so that's
starting to get into
um starting to get into italian
areas
um
dominican in ottawa so canada right it's
already spreading into the
french-speaking
parts there and and you also i mean
you know like like uh steinberg is in um
is in uh belgium right or the
netherlands um
and then by yeah by like like the
35 we're seeing um i mean it's still
mostly french but we're starting to see
it hitting
other places as well
um oh the the american catholic
philosophical association one
was in 36 because james kelly uh
does a a talk which then gets and so
does harry mcneil
they both do something there so there
were other there were other
um languages and places where things are
happening
but it's really cycling around these
these french things because you've got
the society
frances de philosophy which is a big
thing includes a lot of catholics a lot
of
secular thinkers you've got the
society detude for the sophie
based in marseille that blondel is
participating in
marcel's participating in bregier is
participating in
pretty regularly you've got all these
important journals
you know like uh esprit and viante
review metaphysical morale so there's
all this back and forth going on
um and it's mostly it's mostly
francophone all right
i should also mention the society tom
east right they start having their very
first
meetings and the society to east is
bringing together it's in its
stuff is in french but it's bringing
together thomas from all over europe and
so you know the very first session
uh the the guest was edith stein and it
was devoted to phenomenology
and they talked a little bit about
christian philosophy in that one and
then the second one was devoted entirely
to christian philosophy and so it had a
multinational kind of
flavor to it but it really was centered
in in france
um mark has any contribution from the
latin american world
not at the time of the debates
but there are some articles later on
written about the problem of christian
philosophy or about the debates
by latin american authors i don't know
if there were any brazilian authors
writing in portuguese i know that there
were
authors writing in spanish
from latin and south america so
all right andre russian is revelation
about determinism i don't even know what
that would mean
um revelation it means something that's
divinely revealed through however
whatever kind of mode it's supposed to
be so when you talk about the bible
as you know christian revelation
um you know all those different books
but i don't know that that has anything
to do with determinism
um oh here's a good question from jed
does anyone win the debates uh
is there any new consensus afterwards
that's a great question
nobody wins the debates as a matter of
fact the
the big representatives like you know so
here's here's some
some stuff coming up um the
jillson martin position and the blondel
position
managed to show some pretty
remarkable uncharity towards each other
not realizing that they're actually
compatible with each other and spend a
lot of polemics fighting each other
and if you ask um american
sort of you know mainstream or
conservative
uh american catholics about the
christian philosophy debates if they
even know about it they think it's a
zhilsan
versus um uh brahir debate and that
blondel wasn't important at all it was
one of the reasons i put so much blondel
in this and they will buy the line
the essentially propaganda that you know
jill so
and maritan and their their students put
out that they won the debates you know
which is basically [ __ ]
um you could be equally triumphalistic
as a blundellian
londell didn't win the debates either
nobody really won the debates what the
debates did is widened
the scope of
discussion and put the really important
issues on the table
who did lose the debates the
rationalists very clearly because they
had nothing to say
after you know just a little bit in the
debates
um but you know i kind of think and i am
eclectic in this what we what we want is
a recognition that there were a lot of
really good points
made and elaborated by a lot of
different
people and sides in the debates so
um and you know when interestingly when
jill so
entered into it he's like debates never
solve anything
he said this when when it was proposed
to him in the first place
and he he almost like didn't do it
uh in part because he's like no no
everybody just
comes with their ideas already fixed and
they're not going to
budge on anything you know and and
really what it came down to i mean
blondel
did in fact um make some additional
uh he took in
what his critics had to say made some
additional um
changes in in his ideas you could say
uh not not at the foundational level but
more like yeah yeah you got a good point
there we have to we have to take that
into consideration he definitely backed
off
on his criticism of
tomism which was quite
strong in his early works which were you
know 30 years before this
um just
i don't think really changed much i
don't think maritime didn't
um marcel you i guess you could say
you know his thought evolved through the
debates
all right well thanks b uh
i can't really make out what that little
guy is doing
um in the cartoon uh negro cornelia
thank you for all your work oh you're
very welcome
um thomas says do you have any interest
in joseph peeper he's a good little
treatment on faith as well as hell
revelation and reason
it's polyphonic counterpoint by way of
analogy i've read him before
i just never really got into paper
you know i read him as a grad student
but
um and people like him but i
you know we only have so much time so
he's not somebody i've
gone back to um i'm sure he's got a lot
of interesting things to say that that
i've forgotten about at this point but
you can only read so much so
zachary has an irrelevant question here
how do you think christopher columbus
justified his faith in christianity
in committing atrocious acts i don't
know i'm sure you could probably look
that up
you know there's he probably wrote
plenty of stuff down
i am not a christopher columbus ologist
know i mean people will find take
religion out of the picture and just
think of
all sorts of asshole-ish behavior that
people engage in
just in day-to-day life how do they
justify those things to themselves
you know what are the psychological
dynamics that they use
i'm willing to bet christopher columbus
probably used some similar
things uh an angry cornelia do you think
people are good or bad at the root
uh i think they're they're um they have
potentiality for both
you know i mean this is kind of a basic
aristotelian point
um you know uh
there's there's a lot of you know a lot
of things we don't have an awful lot of
really strong
instincts but the ones that we do seem
to be good
um like you know wanting to take care of
children but
then again it doesn't get you that far
look how many crappy parents there are
out there
um so i i don't i i don't really have
much of a
a statement on good or bad at the the
root i'm more interested in
once we've actually started to pay
attention to ourselves
and realize just how what a mess we are
how do we make ourselves better
you know um
thomas gerard peepler's argument is that
a good intellectually honest philosopher
should consider the datum
of a text or claim purported to be
divinely revealed
okay well then he's in a large company
of people who think that
you know you can take something that
people say is divinely revealed and you
can you can look at
you know what its meaning is or you know
what it's what it's grounding is
um sort of like you know when we do the
bible as literature classes
in high school and we say we're not
going to worry about whether
you know uh whether this thing actually
happened or not what's the meaning of
this story
you know um
spinoza do you think christian
philosophy can be independent from the
historical claims of christ's death and
resurrection
i don't know why it would want to be but
christian philosophy isn't all about
christ all the time you know i mean when
we say christian
what we're talking about is things done
by christians within this
vast universe of signification covering
2000 years and you know
um thousands of people who've
written and that's part of the christian
matrix so
um does everything have to be you know
always coming back to christ all the
time
probably not so it depends if that if
that's what you mean
by independent then i guess it could be
independent
if you mean like do you could you have
christian philosophy where you never
talk about christ
probably not i mean could you have could
you have uh
uh buddhist practice where you never
talk about the buddha
probably not you know um
negro do you think the planet would be a
better place without religion or worse i
think
those sorts of questions are so
incredibly abstract that
there's no there's no answer for it
there's no definition of what what
constitutes religion
and i mean it's been such an integral
part of most societies
and still does remain so to today what
would you possibly compare it against
you know thomas has got to go thanks for
engaging yeah i've got it
it's time for me to go too actually um
b what are your thoughts on christ and
paul's rhetorical styles do they have
anything to offer us today
i don't know i mean i i'm not i'm not
reading the stuff for the rhetoric
um christ doesn't have a rhetorical
style what we have are the gospel
writers
maybe that's what you mean we have uh
gospel writers
records pretty pretty you know not very
long at all right we don't know an awful
lot about the guy
it's not like you know the hadith in
uh islam where we've got all these the
guy said this the guy said this the guy
said this you know they're pretty short
um i mean can you learn from anybody's
rhetoric i suppose
but i i you know i'm not a rhetorician
so
all right um cena says i learned so much
from the four vorts the
preface of the phenomenology thanks a
lot oh you're welcome
so we're gonna do another one of these
uh probably next weekend
and i'm gonna keep plowing my way you
know
you look at how big this book is right
there's gonna be a lot of
readings in order to get through this
but glad people have enjoyed it i'm
i'm getting a kick out of rereading this
stuff that i wrote
you know um a long time ago and and
saying oh that's that's a pretty good
turn of phrase there
so all right uh you stay tuned to the
channel and you can you can find out
when
when we're going to have them you can
also look at the you know reason io
events calendar
my my facebook page um
events calendar those will tell you when
these are coming up
so where some of you i know it's evening
for you
some it's probably early morning here
it's afternoon so have a
good day everybody and i'll see you next
time